an unfortunate theme of the Trump
administration is that the world laughs
at us
okay the United Nations General Assembly
laughed at Donald Trump when he tried
claiming that his administration has
accomplished more than any American
presidential administration in history
the leaders of Mexico and Canada were
visibly stunned as Donald Trump couldn't
figure out how to sign a piece of paper
we've covered many examples of the world
laughing at Trump on the program before
right climate talks got underway in
Poland and as I told you yesterday the
United States is already in this
coalition with Russia Saudi Arabia and
Kuwait who are not welcoming an IPCC
report about climate change they are
saying we don't want to welcome this
we're okay
noting it but we don't want it being any
kind of central piece of the climate
talks in Poland why because those are
some of the biggest oil producing
countries in the world and they don't
want a piece of evidence welcomed which
says the activities of those four oil
producers producing countries are a
major part of the problem we're
experiencing on planet earth okay
so cut to yesterday in Poland Donald
Trump sent a guy named Wells Griffith
Griffith is Trump's advisor on energy
and climate that's who went to the
conference he gets up there and he
promotes coal and fossil fuels at a
climate conference and the crowd
literally laughs out loud and then a
protest breaks out take a look at the
video clear energy innovation and fossil
fuels will continue to play a leading
role the access
Thanks
I hope you'll give us a chance yeah so I
think the chant is keep it in the ground
like keep the fossil fuels in the ground
so okay in in the defense of Wells
Griffith far be it for me to issue a
defense of going through a climate
conference and suggesting that coal and
fossil fuels were what we should be
focusing on in this guy's defense this
was not spontaneous laughter I I'm aware
of that the crowd was ready with a
banner and a chance and it was a
coordinated protest but it doesn't
change the reality Pat that going to a
climate conference representing one of
four countries opposed to this IPCC
climate study and talking about fossil
fuels it is a joke and the only
reasonable response to that other than
crying is laughter like what do you
expect to happen I mean you're going in
there taking the opposite view of pretty
much everyone at that conference if not
everyone at that conference you deserve
to be laughed at like you're the goals
that they're trying to accomplish you're
at complete odds with who sends a coal
guy to a climate conference in 2018 it's
a sham and an embarrassment and we are
in a time where the right has been very
successful at stigmatizing things that
really shouldn't be stigmatized the
right has won at stigmatizing science as
left-wing when it's just science the
right has stigmatized education as
liberal indoctrination because when you
are educated you realize that those
silly right-wing ideas make no sense and
you become more more likely to be
progressive but education in and of
itself is not liberal indoctrination but
they've four
as such the right has stigmatized
decency and empathy as being liberal
extreme points of view but when it comes
specifically to the climate they have
associated fossil fuels with economic
prosperity which is what's backwards you
can't have a successful economy when the
planets destroyed right if our coastal
cities are underwater that's really bad
for jobs that's really bad for
manufacturing that's really bad for
transportation that's bad for the
economy it's terrible
okay environmental sustainability should
be seen as economically advantageous
because it is even if it weren't
economically advantageous it might still
be the right thing to do even if for
example slavery kept costs down when
slavery was legal if slavery was
profitable it still could be wrong and
we should still stop it and in this case
it just so happens that when it comes to
the climate in the environment and
energy the economically advantageous
thing happens to also be the morally
correct thing great what a wonderful
coincidence but they have successfully
framed that is the opposite good luck
trying to convert the current
administration over to the reality of
the world until they're gone this isn't
going to change and so our goal needs to
basically be two parallel goals number
one mitigate the damage done to the
environment and on this issue of climate
by the Trump administration as much as
possible because they're not going to
change limit the damage they're able to
do and we've got to get these people to
hell out of there right because that
that's the only chance we have and if it
doesn't happen in 2020 that's going to
be four more years of this nonsense an
absolute and total joke the United
States which Trump said was a
laughingstock under Obama even though it
wasn't right I mean every poll showed
that respect for the United States was
up once President Obama replaced george
w bush now we are literally the
laughingstock of the world and you have
a candidate in trump a president in
trump whose followers see that laughter
from the rest of the world as a badge of
honor because they believe we just know
the true
and everybody else is wrong absolutely
ridiculous
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show where we
now have really great clips from the
show with subtitles very shareable
really really great stuff including
maybe this story we'll make it on there
at david pakman show on instagram while
you're there you can follow me on
instagram at david pakman we will take a
break next I will speak to Lisa Lacey
what is in the cards for human robot
interaction in the next five to ten
years that's what we'll talk about right
after the break one of the day's
sponsors is privacy calm slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started
and for a limited time they're giving
everyone in our audience $5 towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link